foreign
[Music]
especially when dancing's involved
the Grammy winner hit up a Halloween
bash and when the DJ Spins a Rihanna
classic Adele does what anyone would do
dance all your time
[Music]
yeah there's Adele all suited up but
getting down with a dancer who was
really in the Halloween spirit we're not
exactly used to seeing Adele break it
down but those knees and those wrists
are working it's been a complete
Whirlwind but it's like so much fun as
well and that song
yeah it's fitting because much like her
girl Rihanna I knew this was the
question I is Rihanna turns out Adele
likes her name pronounced a certain way
too by Adele I'm Annie and I'm from
London where is she from Enfield or
something I love that she said my name
perfectly yeah guys it's not Adele it's
Adele and while we're at it don't bother
using Adele's last name either
Adele Watkins does not have the same
ring I think it sounds Rich it sounds
Rich up next for Adele she is heading to
Vegas to kick off her long-awaited
residency later this month shows she
previously canceled due to the pandemic
and a lack of time to prepare
I can't give you what I have right now
um and I'm guided I'm guided and I'm
sorry it's so last minute but before the
singer takes the stage in Sin City she's
floating down a river of wine literally
a bit drunk
it all goes down in her latest music
video for I drink wine which dropped
last week
[Music]
[Applause]
so I just want to love you
of you free yeah cause everybody wants
something from me